foreign
Justin is with us Justin's in Columbia
Tennessee hi Justin welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi Jade how are you doing today great
how can we help
so um I'm calling because honestly a
little scared to try not to get stupid
after scared
um my wife and I wrapped that baby step
two right before we moved a couple
months ago our second car was in an
accident we bought a hooptie with the
insurance money that car just failed on
us and our one working vehicle is
needing some repairs and we're
struggling with needing a second car and
everything and
um I'm feeling like I'm being moved
towards a personal level and I don't
want to go that route good
okay so what do you what's your
household income
the um we're about 45 000. okay
all right and you have how much money in
savings
um about 300 we depleted most of the
emergency fund right after we moved with
a couple things that needed to be done
on our primary vehicles
okay all right so the primary vehicle
needs more repairs
um mostly small things right now that
you know we don't want to let those go
and have them become big things
absolutely I want to let them go you're
broke
okay that adds that adds to the drama
when you when you escalate those little
things to make them big things you're
adding to your drama
okay and so you drive one vehicle for a
little while and you work three jobs and
you pile up some money and you go buy
you another hooptie for four thousand
bucks
all right yeah just we're both working
so um thankfully it's at the same place
and they're working with us on the
scheduling and getting back and forth in
one vehicle yeah I mean it's this is a
time you're going to look back as you
say that time in our life sucked
okay but you're going to make it suck
more if you go back in debt
now Justin you're both working two jobs
and the outcome is forty five thousand
yeah
um you're both working we're both
working
um at a Chick-fil-A currently because
they were willing to work with both of
us for scheduling
um I was self-employed pre-covered
um trying to work on building that back
up I was a subcontractor for on-site I.T
um you know I was traveling out a couple
hundred miles a day you know how to do
it work and you're working at
Chick-fil-A
um I'm working on catching up on some of
my certifications so I can actually get
into more competitive positions
in the meantime you know how to do stuff
90 of the public doesn't know how to do
yes and it pays more than Chick-fil-A
pays
without the certification there's a
subcontractor most of the companies are
paying equivalent and making me wait a
lot longer for the money
the equivalent to Chick-fil-A
yes
okay uh well I want you doing a whole
bunch of that side work also
and I want you to get your butt in gear
and get your income up because I think
Jade put her finger right on it you guys
aren't making any money I'm not mad at
Chick-fil-A they're wonderful that's not
supposed to be your career job
that's that's true when you know it yeah
unless you own the place it's Jesus
chicken part-time job dude I mean if
you're not one of the owners yeah that's
the deal and it's a wonderful place to
have a little part-time job if you're a
teenager rights but not feeding a family
with a broken car no i t i t i t i t i t